remercier notre h
ukrainien tout particulièrement vous
dimitro et bien sûr le président
zens pour c très bonne
hospitalité aujourd'hui nous avons eu
une rencontre informelle des ministres
des Affaires étrangères de l'Union
européenne à
Kiev c'est évidemment un jour historique
pour plusieurs
raisons c'est la première
fois
se réunit en dehors de l'Union
Européenne c'est la première fois que
nous nous réunissons dans un pays
candidat et malheureusement c'est aussi
c'était aussi la première
fois que les ministres des Affaires
étrangères de l'Union européenne se
rencontrait dans un pays en
guerre bien sûr
nous aurions
préféré nous rencontrer dans des
circonstances différente mais ces
circonstances sont ce qu'elles sont et
nous devons soutenir l'Ukraine face à ce
défi en venant à Kiev l'Union européenne
les ministres des Affaires étrangères de
l'Union européenne ont envoyé un message
de solidarité de soutien fort à
l'Ukraine face à cette guerre injuste et
illégitime personnellement avant la
rencontre d'aujourd'hui j'ai je suis
allé visiter Odessa et Kiev pour aller à
la rencontre du peuple
ukrainien pour comprendre leur vie
cotidienne et voir de mes propres
yeux la nature brutale et inhumaine de
l'agression de Poutine contre ce pays il
cible les sites d'héritage culturel les
ports les églises des ports qui
permettent d'alimenter les gens qui ont
faim partout dans le monde cela montre
le véritable visage de cette soi-disante
opération militaire
spéciale que Poutine mène contre le
peuple ukrainien le peuple ukrainien qui
résiste avec une bravoure incroyable la
Russie instrumentalise la
fin la Russie le fait et elle étant
ainsi ses crimes partout dans le monde
en ciblant les peuples les plus
vulnérables en Afrique et en Asie leur
interdisant l'accès à la nourriture
c'est ça la conséquence de ce blocus
naval et ce n'est pas juste nous qui
l'affirmons c'est aussi la perception de
beaucoup de par le monde et nous l'avons
vu au cœur de l'assemblée générale des
nations- Unies il y a 2
semaines malheureusement la Russie euh
est déterminée à continuer ses actions
illégales en violation
des règles
internationales ce qui veut dire que
nous devons travailler et être plus uni
que jamais nous avons commencé à le
faire enfin ça fait des mois que nous le
faisons mais aujourd'hui cette
discussion nous a donné une idée plus
claire de la dimension sécuritaire de
cette situation ça a été une discussion
centrale aujourd'hui avec le président
zelini avec le ministre
koueva nous avons parlé des engagements
de sécurité que nous voulons accorder à
l'Ukraine pour montrer notre
détermination à soutenir l'Ukraine à
long terme pour dissuader des actes
d'agression et résister aux efforts de
déstabilisation de la
Russie vous imaginez sans doute qu'il y
a différents
aspects concernant notre engagement
durable ça va au-delà bien sûr de
l'aspect
militaire je propose une nouvelle
enveloppe bilatérale
multiannuelle de l'Union européenne
de 5 milliards pour l'année prochaine au
singulier et il y aura plus d'argent
ensuite et j'espère que nous trouverons
un accord avant la fin de l'année où les
États-membres doivent tomber d'accord
lors de leur passage en revue du cadre
multiannuel nous continuons à former les
soldats Ukrainiens la cible aujourd'hui
c'est de former 40000 soldats Ukrainiens
dans les mois à venir ce qui inclut de
l'entraînement spécialisé pour les
pilotes d'avion de chasse nous
travaillons
aussi pour le renforcement de la
coopération entre l'industrie de défense
européenne et ukrainienne nous avons av
on eu une rencontre importante à ce
sujet à Kiev il y a quelques jours et
nous continuerons à
travailler pour augmenter la résilience
dans le domaine de la cyberdéfense et
pour se défendre contre les menaces
hybrides tes que la désinformations et
les attaques sur les systèmes de
communication il est important de
continuer à soutenir et d'améliorer
notre soutien pour déminer l'Ukraine ce
qui est clé pour la
reconstruction de l'Ukraine et son
rétablissement économique nous parlons
également de réforme approfondies du
secteur de la police de la justice avec
le
renforcement
de conseil européen auprès de
l'Ukraine et bien sûr l'engagement
sécuritaire le plus ferme que nous
pouvons faire auprès de l'Ukraine c'est
l'adhésion à l'Union européenne c'est
vraiment l'engagement clé pour
l'Ukraine l'Ukraine à présent est un
pays
candidat et elle avance sur cette
voie nous avons parlé de guerre des for
militair de résilience de cyberataque
mais nous avons aussi parlé de paix et
nous
devons chercher la
paix et parler des réformes
pour l'adhésion de l'Ukraine au
processus bruxellois d'ici la fin de
l'année l'Union européenne le Conseil de
l'Union européenne recevra le rapport de
la Commission concernant le dispositif
d'élargissement qui sera présenté par
moi-même et mon collègue de la
commission une
autre facette importante de ce travail
c'est la
responsabilisation notamment face au
crimes et aux actions inhumaines telles
que la déportation d'enfants la Russie
doit payer pour ses agressions et pour
tous ces
crimes
nous allons travailler sur ces
points en consultation avec l'Ukraine et
comme je l'ai dit
auparabant dans le cadre du processus
d'adhésion il y a en parallèle le
travail vers la paix
nous
notons que la formule de paix du
président Zelenski est la seule
initiative de paix discutter dont il est
parlait au sein de la communauté
internationale les projets rus ont
disparu le seul projet qui attire
l'attention et qui justifie le travail
de la communauté internationale c'est la
proposition du Président
selenski c'est la formule pour la paix
et nous continuerons de travailler en
tant qu'Union européenne pour qu'elle
devienne plus globale et pour qu'elle
devienne la base de la paix
future et maintenant dimitro je vais
vous donner la parole mais avant cela je
veux souligner que cette réunion
conjointe des ministres des Affaires
étrangères de l'Union européenne avec
l'Ukraine à
Kiev devrait être perçu comme un ement
clair de l'Union européenne auprès de
l'Ukraine et comme un signe de notre
soutien continu dans toutes les
dimensions militair pour la paix pour la
responsabilisation et pour la
trajectoire européenne et ça envoie
aussi un signal fort à la
Russie un signal à la Russie qui leur
dit que nous ne sommes pas intimidés par
vos missiles par vos drones
avant après avoir après que j'ai quitté
Odessa il y a une nouvelle salve une
nouvelle pluie de drone dans l'oblast
d'Odessa au moment même où je quittais
la ville nous ne sommes pas intimidés
par vos drones ou par vos
missiles
notre résolution à protéger
l'indépendance et la liberté de
l'Ukraine est ferme et continuera à
l'avenir oui nous continuerons de nous
tenir au côté de
l'Ukraine merci
merci merci beaucoup cher
Josep tout d'abord je tiens à remercier
le haut représentant de l'Union
européenne et tous mes collègues et mes
amis mesdames et messieurs les ministres
merci beaucoup de vous être réuni
aujourd'hui à
Kiev il est vrai que c'est la première
fois où le Conseil des Ministres des
Affaires étrangère de l'Union européenne
se réunit dans un tel format à
l'extérieur des frontières actuelles de
l'Union européenne mais à l'intérieur de
futures frontières de l'Union
européenne et cette réunion dans ce
format est un signal très fort et
éloquent aujourd'hui nous avons non
seulement
parlé de la manière dont nous
repouserons l'agression euh
russe car il y a bien le consensus
autour de cette table que la Russie a
non seulement attaquer l'Ukraine mais a
attaqué euh tous les principes sur
lesquels basé l'Europe toute entière
nous avons aussi abordé les questions
relatives à l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à
l'Union européenne dans l'avenir car il
y a aussi un consensus qui dit que c'est
la question de temps et la partie
ukrainienne et la partie européenne sont
prête à avancer en ce sens aussi
rapidement que possible en tenant compte
de toutes les réformes que l'Ukraine
conduit et
conduira et le signal clé
aujourd'hui consistait à dire que nous
mettrons en œuvre les SEP
recommandations émises par la Commission
européenne pour ouvrir les négociations
en vue d'adhésion et nous nous attendons
à ce que cette évaluation soit menée
honnêtement et sans émettre des
exigences supplémentaires et nous avons
une
compréhension mutuelle en ce
sens avec la Commission
européenne Monsieur Joseph Borel a bien
présenté le sens de nos négociations
aujourd'hui et je
mettrai l'accent sur un autre élément le
12e paquet de sanctions il y a eu une
analyse de ce qui est faisable ce qui
marche ce qui fonctionne moins bien et
pourquoi le deuxem paquet de sanction
n'est pas encore approuvé et bien nous
avons émis un appel à l'union européenne
à se pencher sur ce Dee paquet de
sanctions en mettant l'accent sur deux
aspects tout d' abord les mesures
nécessaires pour lutter contre le
contournement des sanctions déjà mises
en place et ensuite deuxièmement les
nouvelles sanctions qui
concerneraient l'industrie de défense et
desésarmement de la Fédération de Russie
qui produit les missiles et les drones
envoyés sur les villes ukrainiennees
pour les détruire
ensuite il y a toutes les raisons pour
se pencher sur les sanctions contre
l'industrie de l'Atom l'industrie
nucléaire russe et puis nous avons aussi
parlé de la responsabilisation en ce qui
concerne les propagandistes russes donc
nous sommes ouverts à travailler avec
l'Union européenne euh en ce sens
ensuite nous souhaiterions remercier
l'Union européenne d'avoir élaboré ce
dispositif pour l'Ukraine Ukraine
facility nous voyons un accord très
large pour continuer le financement du
Fond européen pour la paix qui finance
la formation pour les militaires
ukrainiens et les livraisons des armes
et des munitions à notre
pays et donc là aussi
nous nous nous attendons à ce que
l'initiative sur la livraison des
munitions et des
obus se mett en place et nous remercions
Joseph Borel car beaucoup d'avancé en ce
sens ont lieu grâce à l'initiative du
Haut
représentant Joseph Borel a aussi
mentionné le forum des industries de
défense qui a eu lieu à Kiev la semaine
dernière
effectivement c'est un appel au pays de
faciliter la coopération de leurs
industries de défense avec l'industrie
de défense ukrainienne
pour mettre en place les processus pour
les armements et les munitions
nécessaires car c'est un sujet important
pour tous les pays européen et non
seulement pour l'Ukraine
euh j'ai aussi
mentionné l'importance de rendre plus
actif le travail sur la base juridique
qui est permettra de transférer à
l'Ukraine les actifs russes confisqués
ou
gelés il y a bien des questions de droit
à résoudre par les juriste euh dans euh
le cadre
euh de l'État de droit donc ces
dispositifs juridiques peuvent être
trouvés et ce transfert d'actifs
confisqués faciliterait la vie à tous
aussi bien à l'Ukraine qui obtiendra des
ressources supplémentaires mais aussi à
l'Union européenne qui aura enfin trouvé
une
solution précise que faire avec ces cet
argent gelé et
confisqué
pour
pouvoir transférer
ce
fardau car tout le monde est d'accord
que la Russie doit payer pour ce qu'elle
a fait et puis
ceci également permettra de soulager ces
ce fard au d'argent gelé
ensuite nous avons abordé la question
des marchés
internationaux coopération avec l'Asie
l'Afrique l'Amérique
latine tout le monde met sa pierre à
l'édifice et notre signal est très clair
le couloir
maritime qui
permet
d'exporter le grain rainien vers le
monde sans faire participer la Russie et
bel et bien une réalité qui
fonctionne et si l'Union européenne a
des possibilités de garantir la sécurité
de renforcer la sécurité nous pourrons
trouver une bonne solution pour ces
exportations car nous devons chercher
ensemble avec les Européens la euh
possibilité
d'exporter pour que la Russie n'empêche
pas les exportations des céréales
nécessaires pour le monde entier nous
pouvons le faire sans la Russie comme
nous l'avions fait
avant cette invasion russe nous avons
aussi abordé la question du Tribunal
spécial pour juger le crime d'agression
de la Russie contre l'Ukraine il y a eu
des idées fort intéressantes qui ont été
est mise et qui mérite d'être
approfondie et puis le sujet extrêmement
important qui a été à l'ordre du jour
aujourd'hui
c'est l'intégration européenne
de
l'Ukraine l'Ukraine veut devenir membre
de l'Union européenne et donc
l'ouverture des négociations en vue
d'adhésion avant la fin de l'année et
notre souhait et nous euh nous sentions
vraiment autour de cette table comme un
des membres de la famille européenne qui
partage les principes et les valeurs
européennes et nous sommes tous prêts à
nous soutenir mutuellement car nous
formons une seule famille unie et ceci a
été à nouveau démontré aujourd'hui à
Kiev autour de cette table et je
remercie encore Joseph Borel à de cette
visite avec tous les ministres des
Affaires étrangères de l'Union
européenne et pour ces négociations
fructueuses monsieur Borel il semble que
la Russie se prépare à une longue guerre
l'Europe
at plus divisé le symbolisme c'est bien
mais pourriez-vous nous dire quelles
sont les garanties concrètes que vous
fournissez à
l'Ukraine
quelles sont les garanties que vous leur
fournissez notamment en terme
d'infrastructure
énergétique et que fait l'Allemagne de
ce point de
vue l'Union européenne reste unie dans
son soutien à
l'Ukraine nous sommes tout à fait Unis
il faut le
souligner je ne vois pas d'état membre
qui recul face à engagement pour
soutenir
l'Ukraine et quant à ce que nous faisons
concrètement je pense que je l'ai déjà
expliqué je ne pense pas nécessaire de
me répéter ce que je vous ai dit ce que
nous allons faire nous allons continuer
à faire ce que nous avons fait et en
faire
plus nous mettons sur la table des
requêtes financières auprès des
États-membres qui décident du côté civil
ce qu'ils peuvent faire pour soutenir
l'économie
ukrainienne il faut à la fois soutenir
l'effort de guerre et vous savez qu'il y
a une proposition de 50 milliards
d'euros et du côté
militaire il va falloir faire un fond
spécifique européen pour continuer à
soutenir l'Ukraine de ce point de vue
comme nous l'avons dit pour les quatre
prochaines années il y a un engagement
et il y a 5 milliards de plus pour
l'année à
venir c'est ça que nous allons faire je
comprends que ce ne sont pas des
déclarations inédites mais c'est ça que
nous faisons pour continuer à soutenir
l'Ukraine et pour augmenter notre
soutien à l'Ukraine c'est ça dont
l'Ukraine a besoin c'est ce que nous
continuerons de
faire je peux
répondre
à tous ceux qui
essayent de créer l'impression ou de
faire croire qu'il y aurait soit-disant
une lassitude ou une faiblesse dans le
soutien vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine et bien
cela n'arrivera pas car nous trouvons
des
solutions dans toutes les
situations et
Poutine aspire à ce que l'Occident et le
monde entier éprouve cette laassitude et
abandonne le soutien vis-à-vis de
l'Ukraine et des ressources importantes
sont lancé pour cela
mais de toute façon
là l'interaction la coopération continue
et il il y a parfois des bruits qui
courent mais moi je
soutiens la
position qui dit que la Russie
représente la menace pour le monde
entier et nous
avons ici l'unité de nos positions car
les 27 ministres des Affaires étrangères
et le
représentant de l'Union européenne et
autres représentants de la Commission
européenne se sont tous réunis ici et ce
n'est pas seulement un soutien
symbolique c'est un instrument précis
concret et qui démand toute la rhtorique
ou le narratif qui essaie de faire
croire en absence de l'unité
il y a bien la volonté politique c'est
démontré aujourd'hui ici et nous parlons
des choses très
concrètes nous avons abordé toute la
panoplie des question y compris la
défense anti-aérienne et je citerai la
ministre des Affaires étrangères d'un
des pays qui a dit je la cite nous
faisons tout N même pour que l'Ukraine
obtienne aussi rapidement que possible
les nouveaux systèmes de défense
anti-aérienne pour passer l'hiver en
sécurité et nous appelons tous les
autres membres de l'Union européenne à
soutenir cette initiative je pense que
cet appel a été
entendu monsieur le ministre
kou j'ai une question pour
vous
il y a des euh discussions euh pour la
préparation et les réformes
institutionnelles pour l'adhésion est-ce
que ces réformes peuvent
être achev ou ce processus peut durer
longtemps et
pourriez-vous
expliquer ce que Premier ministre
schmeekal
a dit récemment en parlant de l'adhésion
à l'Union européenne
où l'Ukraine ne devrait pas être un
membre de
seconde
àabi là je pense que l'Union européenne
comprend
que les
réformes pour l'Union européenne ne
peuvent pas être sans fin nous notre
signal que nous transmettons à tous à
tous les niveaux et que à aucun moment
nous ne pouvons euh laisser utiliser le
sujet de réforme de l'Union
européenne comme instrument qui
freinerait l'avancée des candidats vers
l'Union européenne tel que l'Ukraine ou
les pays des Balcans
occidentaux je pense que nous sentirons
bien si la réforme de l'Union européenne
est utilisé comme instrument pour
freiner cette avancée ce n'est pas le
cas actuellement mais le processus est
compliqué et parfois quand je parle aux
collègues européens je plaisante
fait de sorte que les réformes
ukrainiennes ne devanent pas les
réformes de l'Union européenne qu'elle
n'avance pas plus rapidement que les
vôtres mais nous avons sérieusement
parlant un très bon dialogue en ce sens
en ce qui concerne votre 2e
question il n'y a pas eu de de
proposition comme vous dites et
évidemment l'Ukraine un pays de première
catégorie comm tous les autres et
nousouons avoir la même place que tous
les autres
pays deè
question je voudrais poser la question
suivante la France et
l'Allemagne qui viserait à accepter
l'Union
européenne accepter l'Ukraine en Union
Européenne mais pas en tant que membre
pleiné entier mais sous un autre format
est-ce que de telles propositions ont
été abordé qu'est-ce que cela veut dire
j'ai déjà répondu à cette question
peut-être Joseph peut
répondre je ne sais pas d'où vient cette
idée
je ne sais tout simplement pas d'où ça
vient ce n'est pas vrai qui qui parle de
qui parle de ça de membres partiel de
membres à 50 % 25 % on est membrre on
est membre c'est
tout comment comment voulez-vous je
comment voulez-vous je vous l'explique
vous voulez que je vous le
répète un État membre c'est un État
membre c'est
tout alors malheureusement on n pas plus